[Music]
and
in
[Music]
Oh
don't try to find a way to fall this
crash
[Music]
I'm going to aim through your Center on
to your left way
Oh
don't walk around the back of this
feature lets you plot nothing got it I
have to feel what I'm doing we can't
bring all of her weight over weight
comes on to it
this is wait going around wait on
[Music]
this body is basically doing this so you
had a week same thing he is doing last
night same exact thing this angle and
then you project across you usually see
it over them so and then you would
project across so we're doing it from
this side so I'm not pulling him
backwards you see I'm not calling him
back
I'm rotating him
not yet he was coming forward I keep
them going okay got it give you some I
need that other leg to come around this
way I need it to come around you don't
want to be afraid but I'm not letting
them take a step so I make it come
around this is not it around
[Music]
don't do it for me
I'll go wait on this leg you see that
then circle her head but I find that the
arm Hey she will rotate around and turn
towards me this arm is here stopping
that can't go so it's going you might
start here and there might be some
integrity to it but once you guys feel
her leg come forward then you guys go
like that you see that and then you're
gonna show that that is the time where
we actually need the pressure okay so
I'm here boom this arm is there not not
over here I'm gonna pull you down it's
over here yeah you did it for me you're
so light I can throw you to the window
you learn because you won't feel it
won't just stay there
got it watch me you feel that I'll be
late that's words face it I'm just like
mmm so I gotta take get rid of that leg
yeah watch my back so that they can't
come back so it has to go forward and
not back where it is tiny
don't come here wool and then they run
backwards on you
hey let's just work on the floor then I
take it off then I put your weight on
the leg but
then this comes here then it starts to
get heavy
[Music]
the figure-eight wool right now she's
gonna come this way on the a your exam
possible basis supported so wool she's
going to come this way